and I said you're a homosexual and I
have no problem with that because over
the summer men in Munich paid me to
defecate thousands of tourists every day
come and they stand in front of this
pink wall and nobody shoots them in the
face with the kids
I was inappropriate with the [ __ ]
listen those guys are lucky I didn't
[ __ ] up I want to see the [ __ ] the
guy's the king of [ __ ] pop you know
he's [ __ ] all the time Nazis
it's got to be oj - I want Hogg at
Madison Square Garden people are turning
in their guns and crying I'm gonna
[ __ ] get you my mother took her own
life last year and before I before I
call the police I tried a few moves on
her but I won't [ __ ] you because the
only person I'll [ __ ] is daddy
[ __ ] women are running the
military-industrial complex now the
future is female fetch wasn't a bad dude
Jerri honesty you know he's not a bad
[ __ ] doing hustle is the most
important word ever what about the word
jug did somebody show me how to get home
this is all part of the sting operation
- s'mores the mouse being the victim of
racism on Twitter he's worse than
getting stabbed 95 times in your
Brentwood home Dizzy's been my favorite
since I'm a child and I'm still a child
at heart I'm 48 years old if there were
real pedophiles in there they would be
[ __ ] deep in me two or three of the
time now I have seven personal trainers
and three of them have killed themselves
or Kelly likes piss what is he supposed
to like old this even when Hillary
Clinton was slicing the throats of
children and I said I just want to make
people laugh my owner is dead ish I was
in the store you know people don't know
how to act
hey Dad
she's not pressing charges in my day
kids shoveled snow they didn't cut their
dicks off to spike Christ it should be
coyotes about here but they've all been
killed by Satan I want to [ __ ] somebody
on a boat and then blow their brains out
as I'm coming come on in it's like a
Micah wish for billionaires really that
was part of what it was it's Christmas
time it's about to come clean [ __ ]
[Applause]